ever since I was a little kid
I found great resonance in the work of
Salvador Dali the father of surrealism
created imagery that was unsettling to
say the least his imagery spoke of an
innerverse of an altered state of a
space with a kind of dream logic that
made us question our assumptions and
quickly violated our expectations it
agitated us into a different space and a
different mode there was something of
imagination but there was also something
of transgression like we were bearing
witness to a Forbidden World an
interiority that is normally private or
turmoil our fantasy our ecstasy our
orgiastic manic geometries there was
something about Salvador Dali that spoke
of forbidden fruits and indulgences and
easy and Madness there was something
about it that said I dare you to pay
visitation to these Realms with me it
was a like Eric Davis describing Burning
Man a demolition derby of reality
constructs colliding on a parched void
there was something about Dali that
spoke to us and I wonder what this means
because human beings we are also
creatures of logic and rationality
Science and Enterprise but we love
Madness and we love mania and we love
bewilderment and creativity we love the
inversion of the normal world to move
from Kronos to Kairos to leave the
rationality behind and pay visitation to
a different kind of dream logic a space
beyond the literal grid and it is in
these spaces where something new reveals
itself to us about who we are in our
greatest moment
about our greatest potential but the
role we have to play as novelty
engendering engines tricksters or as
Jamie wheel said truth-telling liars and
we like this like Cinema with its false
reality genres hinting at the moments
when we tumble down the rabbit hole and
Baseline reality dissolves and a new
mysterium emerges in its pixelating wake
we are in Play We Are enthralled we are
well
We Are The Lost Boys from Never Never
Land and we refuse to grow up staying
instead in the realm of the artist The
Poet the Mad Men the men who moved to
the woods to lose their mind and find
their soul
place
of poetry